欢迎收听赵华语古惑仔帝1146集
这个集数怎么已经跟跌点快要接近了
今天是2026年的7月24号
星期五上一个星期五真的是黑色星期五
因为那一天是史上最大的跌点
那今天当然没有创下史上最大的跌点
可是跌了1195点
也算跌了蛮多就是一个千点以上
那因为之前我们在投资上面的惯性
觉得台股真的很厉害
跌破月线马上站回来
那这次跌破季线
大家也希望跌破季线马上站回来
那事实上前两天
有试图以大盘来说
试图反攻到月线的附近
但是被盖头压
那今天再一根下去
自然有所谓的国际市场的一些因素
大家也不免要问
感觉不舒服了
因为本来以为我的持股
已经算是有点回血了
结果今天又杀一个一千多点
而且今天中小新谷的状况还是不理想的
所以很多人又觉得今天又吐血了
大家可以有这样的感觉
而且今天的量能如果没有杀的话
刚开盘的时候是一度预估量不到7000亿
我那时候还在想说会不会叫做窒息量
其实窒息量也不错
因为我们也知道如果是跌下来窒息
有时候它反而是一个落底的讯号之一
大量也可以窒息也可以
但后来跌跌还是稍微出了一点点的量
所以我们就一直在低量
然后盘起不来的状态下
折磨着我们
那要如何保持信心呢
我们今天来的呢
我们刚刚算了一下
他上次来竟然是7月3号星期五
这样就有辱你星期五男孩的名号
好 先来欢迎他
今天有影片版哦
今天来的是我们的国家级基金操盘手
黄峰凯 凯哥
早好 各位观众大家好
因为中间有台风架
然后有一周刚好我们有调动班次
然后结果就到今天
7月3號我剛才特地看了一下
那一天還有46000多點
今天剩下43000多點
一來一回
凱哥沒有出現的星期五
差了3000點
而且這個3000點
說實話因為台積電很沉
所以都殺在中小型財股上面
有夠痛苦
對 有夠痛苦
好 當然以照好來說
今天其實你還沒有破
所謂禮拜一的低點
甚至也沒有破禮拜五的低點
很多股票應該是沒有
但就體感不好
你回血了
今天又掉下去了
是 這個盤基本上
我常常讲嘛
一个指数的趋势是不能月线下弯的
可是目前我们是贵买跟大盘的月线
通通都下弯
没错
对 那通通下弯
贵买一定是跑比较远
那你就要等大盘指纹
那大盘其实昨天一度有要占回大量低
可是今天这个利空消息就把它打下来
那所以告诉你就说
我们之前在讲说
其实第三季是一个难做的季度
还记得吗
我们其实讲过第三季不好做
那第三季度在这个情况之下
基本上我个人觉得啦
最大的跌點應該已經結束了
就是上禮拜五跟今天
大概已經差不多了
再來他可能是不會直接V轉
但是他就是以盤待整
你們今天看到的就是韓國
他在加速的去桿桿
那其實這對台灣也算是一個好消息
就至少他加速完之後
他該殺的殺完一波
他基本上就沒有什麼可下殺的了
那這樣基本上整個國際股市
相對會比較穩住一點
那再來就是你看到
像Google的這個財報其實也不差
可他的資本支出預算提得非常的高
大家也很害怕
那我想說你又要馬而肥
又要馬而不吃草
這有點困難
因為他唯有投入很多的資本支出
他未來才會繳出一個好的成績嘛
所以你不能只看負面
你要往正面角度去想說
欸 他投了這麼多的資本支出
他要往AI去
那就會有人收賄啊
所以誰收賄
其實昨天有漲的
Intel是收賄的
因為這個整個Google的TPU
他的開發是聯發科幫他做開發
台積電幫他做晶圓代工
他的封裝用的不是CoVeut
而是ImiBi
也就是Intel的這個製程
那做完之後再回到台灣來撤
其實這一掛是受惠的
可是因為股市在跌
其實大家就把這一些利多視而不見
就一樣這樣洗刷
但我覺得他就是未來就是一個好事情
就是你的Google投了那麼多的錢
他不會是沒有去處的
而這些錢基本上就投到台灣來
所以我覺得在台灣的供應鏈基本上是好的
但有的人會覺得說那有沒有Intel的供應鏈
我說Intel供應鏈基本上不好找
為什麼因為Intel的供應鏈基本上是台積電的供應鏈
所以不太有特別的
但是我說你可以從聯發科的這一個系列來找相對的標的
例如說像日月光 像歷程這些
他們都是收回Google TPU的部分
那有跌下來其實你就可以去找一個好的買點
那這個時間點因為進入第三季的第一個月
馬上七月就要結束了
所以大家你就会觉得很痛苦
那进入八月中的下旬
我觉得指数就不会给大家这么大的痛苦
就会慢慢好一些
但是这个时间
大概也还要有将近半个月的时间
所以未来两周基本上我觉得
就是你不要过度的去追强势股
因为这个盘是盘整盘
它不是V转
也不是强势上攻的股票的族群
你去攻强势股
你很容易追高它就杀你
它就杀你
你反而去找那个相对
之前已经先压回的
或是我们之前常常讲过
因为筹资而下跌的股票
这个地方其实我觉得
你就可以试图去做一点加码的动作
因为他们已经跌过了
这边就算再跌
其实也跌不了太深
他们顶多就是小跌一些
那你就在那边慢慢见部位嘛
你不要说一跌下来
那这边要握手
那这样就很危险了
你不是用握手的角度
而是用开始见部位的角度
去找这些股票
例如说像今天的矽光子
其实早上联雅就有那个味道
可是我觉得早上应该有当冲跑进去
是
看到尾盘
平盘拉不上去
他就把他往下砍
但我觉得今天他有点是在
取量的一个感觉
就是他低档下他在吃货
所以我们也可以持续的观察
这个族群是不是如凯克之前讲的
CPO在第三季有可能要发光发亮
那再次我们之前讲过的
ABF是不是真的长线这么好
投信一直在买
所以表示投信也认同凯克的看法
外资很奇怪
高盛出一个很好的报告
调高目标价
可是外资一直卖
所以这个地方基本上
它就有一个
让人家摸不着头绪的地方
就是为什么外资要卖
不是很好吗
你们也自己调高目标价
可是为什么讲的跟做的都不一样
其实这地方基本上
就可以花点时间去观察
不过理论上ABF这个族群
基本上它还是位置相对高的
是
对 所以当然在这个行情
大家都已经大盘月线下弯
它当然也要做修正
所以我觉得你把它当作
视为是股价的修正
我觉得应该是比较
match市场的想法
你说它基本面有变坏
我觉得是没有
好 宰板的话
真的波动大啦
看好是看好
大家真的要评估一下
自己在波动里的风险
同样的像这样的族群
就是例如说
它今天全面几乎跌停
今天就有一点这样的味道
这个时候可能你的心
可以大一点点
当然你的资金一定要分批
那如果像前一阵子
前几天其实宰板有全面涨停的
记不记得四雄都涨停
那个时候就不要贸然
在这边觉得你来不及了
一定要追涨停
因为现在的波动在这样的热门族群上真的非常的大
那矽光子大家都知道凯哥一直说
矽光子第三届要发光发热
可是我相信前面开始接的人应该手都软了
因为有的都打到三折了
可是这几天真的最相对抗跌的矽光子
绝对是其中一个很明显的族群
今天发生什么韩国去杠杆的事呢
也帮大家再补充一下
因为韩国不是有发现很多个股的ETF吗
就杠杆型的
台湾没有个股的杠杆型ETF
我们只有加权指数的
那他們本來說8月的時候
要跟收縮購買這些槓桿型
個股ETF的一些資金限制
結果哇 措手不及耶
今天宣布說7月底就實施
我覺得韓國政府蠻猛的
蠻狠的
蠻狠的 你能想像這個發生在台灣嗎
大家能想像說我今天要有一個事情
可能是讓你緊縮
就是讓你不方便買
會傷害到你的目前至少今天的股價的
本來8月才要上路
我忽然就給你上路
這個很兇耶
所以今天韓股一下子又跌到停止交易
因为他就说你户头里的钱
从原本的一千万韩还
你要有三千万韩还
你才可以去买这些杠杆型的商品
而且我只认里面的现金
只有现金才叫资产
哇 立刻七月三十一号
马上上路
没有八月上路
所以这个是韩国今天大跌因为我们开盘的时候其实我们就是我讲有点窒息量有点撑就是這邊你會覺得那應該殺不下去了結果就下去了但是加速趕底這件事情
韓國一定要趕快解決
所以他竟然那麼狠
就是早點了斷
對 早超生
早超生
不過另外一個我覺得讓市場比較煩惱的就是油價了
因為這個可能要請凱哥來聊一下
今天還有一個消息是川普有確定這個關稅嗎
其實這個東西還好
就10到12.5%
其實沒有什麼資錢對等官稅拿出來
什麼40% 50% 沒有這東西
所以我覺得今天官稅應該不是一個罪魁禍首
可是每一戰打不完
導致布蘭特原油已經跑到100塊錢以上了
哇 這個事情有點傷腦筋
這事情就變成在總金面上面
一個有點似乎處理不了的通膨升息
也是資金緊縮的問題
對 就是我們之前講說
因為他們和談了 所以這個油價就跌破了大量低
可是最近又慢慢回到大量中值了
一旦让它这样大量中值
基本上对资本市场相对来讲
它就是一个比较大的影响
对
我不需讲
其实当市场在多头的时候
其实油价或者是通膨
其实对AI股市没有什么影响
你要知道它的影响性非常的小
因为AI的成长非常的大
可是当你的大盘是弱的时候
基本上你已经有点虚了
稍微风吹一下你就感冒了
所以当这个盘进入这个阶段的时候
你就要很小心
所以我想说
你这时候你不要去做
过度的去做追高的动作
甚至你要点做收敛的动作
为什么
我们常讲00632
它就是一个反向指标
可是它现在是大量低站上了
00632大量低站上代表什么
代表就是多空并存的阶段
就这个市场现在是多空并存的
不是存多的
所以你一心的想要存多
你在这地方就会受伤很大
可是它也没有到大量高站上
也没崩盘的意思
大量高站上就是要崩盘
它也没有
所以基本上它就是在这个地方
来回区间的操作
所以在这时间点基本上
你可以就是大量低
要破人去接一点
然后他又再弹上来
然后也过了大量的中值之后
你就可以减一点
因为我个人觉得
因为我开始跟赵华讲说
看起来前低是不会破
前低是不会破
应该也不能讲这么笃定
应该说不会深度跌破
不会说什么跌破了以后
又跌了几千点
应该不适应
因为你现在最大的因素是
第一个是韩国
第二个是油价
那油价基本上
我覺得川普也在猶豫
就是說到底要怎麼去處理這件事情
因為他如果處理的不好
他其中選舉也不用選了
所以這地方他就是
他也兩難
韓國比較不兩難
韓國就直接出手了
其實韓國的事情是直接的
他是直接出手了
其實他這有一點類似什麼概念
就是你房子的自備款
你原本只要兩成
現在突然告訴你說
到下個月你要把你的自備款
提高到五成
對
而且你要拿現金來補
你覺得會有多少能夠收得了
一定很多都收不了
因为你原本是七八成的房贷
你是靠银行在贷款
你突然拿那么多的现金
你哪有办法拿那么多的现金
对不对
所以这个就是很大的压力
所以我觉得让它加速赶底
未必是坏事
让它加速赶底之后
台股反而就不会受到它的拖累
因为你基本上看到
不管是美光或者是三星
不管是海里斯
基本上他们财报没有什么问题
市场的需求还是很强
所以他们现在不是产业面出问题
而是在于制度上出了问题
因为它让他们过度的贪婪
所以现在在收缩这个贪婪
所以你就知道
一个贪婪的心
你要让它回到不贪婪
是不容易的
不容易的
那相对台湾的市场
就没有这个问题
台湾顶多就政二
就是我们是指数政二
我们倒没有个股
可以做到政二这种东西
所以大盆基本上在这地方
有点起伏
所以你要留意的就是
当市场在起伏的时候
要很注意的是产业面的利空
刚刚我们讲到ABF
ABF虽然今天大跌
可是昨天大跌是谁
昨天大跌是真顶
真顶昨天是有利空的
可他今天并没有大跌
他今天大概只有跌4%左右
他有澄清
反而他是真的有利空的
他今天反而没大跌
告诉你说
其实他不是产业面变坏
而是在修正股价
所以像真顶的HDI
早上小朋友就问我说
凯克的HDI
他的做坏了会不会影响很大
我说不会
因为我们在看它的是ABF
不是它的HDI
但HDI现在是市场上很缺喔
包括从滑通
你看滑通要扩厂
代表什么
滑通也要很积极地扩HDI
表示HDI需求很强
所以真宁做坏了
基本上客户不会说
以后我们不要往来
而是说做坏没关系
你赶快把下一批做出来
因为我还很需要HDI的板子
所以告诉你说
产业面是没有什么变化
产业面还是好的
但是个股筹码这边相对要很重视
所以我们常常讲说
产业形态跟筹码
三者要三合一
你不能只看产业
如果你只看产业
你在这地方你就会被卡在泥泞里面
因为产业面没有变化
你就要留意形态跟筹码
现在筹码尤其是形态
产业面没有变化
没错
为什么是多空交战
就是因为产业面跟基本面没有变化
而市场解读的想法变了
昨天有提到Google财报
我们也有跟大家聊
如果在一般顺丰的情况下
他告訴你我要大幅的資本支出
市場一定給你按一個讚
就算是EPS裡面有灌了
所謂的一次性的認利
也沒有關係
扣掉以後還是水準之上
自由現金流轉付
市場看得很嚴重
就覺得雖然你有賺錢
但是入不敷出
才會自由現金流
從2004年以來首度轉付
市場氣氛不好
這件事情就一直被拿出來編
一直被拿出來編
昨天還有特斯拉的財報
它也是自由現金流轉付
特斯拉也照跌
可是奇妙了
那最新公布
就今天凌晨的
Intel财报
怎么大涨呢
Intel怎么了
他也有讲
他说大家的资本支出
对我Intel是有利的
然后我自己的资本支出
今年感觉上
他是没有调整
但明年也会显著的
比今年多
市场就买单了
反正你今年还没有调
你是说明年那没关系
别人资本支出
对你有利那很赞
你的获利盈余
也高出市场运行棒棒
美国政府挺你棒棒
是
所以Intel股票就是在昨天公布財報之後在盤後是大漲的
當然它後來有點受到盤式整體比較冷清的一個壓抑
可是這也證明一件事情
財報都沒有問題好嗎
大家的財報都沒有問題
Intel比較聰明
它不是今年大撒錢
它明年會大撒錢
市場就好沒關係
那你今年沒有大花錢
那就肯定你這樣子
這是一個很奇妙的事情
但是為什麼剛剛講到川普的事情有點棘手
就是顺风的时候
确实油架上去通膨
大家没有那么在意
可是现在就是因为有点逆风
然后又有一个感觉是
你川普老兄
早就说要结束这个战争
每一次都说七天结束
十天结束签和平协议
我不签
这样来回已经要其中选举了
他还搞不定
那为什么会在八月中下旬
你觉得有机会
市场恢复平静呢
我觉得就是说
你要知道
这场战局里面
其实川普的大嘴巴
还是一个很大的一个变数
就是他的大嘴巴会影响到这市场的变化
甚至讲说
你们也可以买我的抗讯啊
我咧呢
对啊 要不要买
天啊
我们不争气的有点想买
对不起
他说提早几毫秒而已
但是也才差几秒钟而已
他说毫秒不是秒
所以基本上
我认为基本上
他仍然是在一个国际的战略的一个思量的角度上
所以他可以让他缓和一点
就是我虽然说
我就不再继续的强攻一郎
那你伊朗也要做一点的退让
我觉得伊朗是愿意的
因为他们在他们的外交端
其实一直有发出讯息说
他们是愿意再跟美国谈的
只是他不愿意就是直接
就是冷气吞声
就说我是完全投降的
那这伊朗大概是不会做
但是他是可以跟美国谈的
所以一旦只要传出说
伊朗跟美国再度和谈
我觉得尤加就马上又跌下去
因为基本上
他纯粹是一个心里面的变化
再就是目前看起来
台湾对于油的需求
其实拖到十月去了
我觉得大家这个油的需求
其实也没有之前那么强
因为之前一段时间是解封了
这个海峡的部分
海峡解封之后
很多的油轮其实都出来了
所以再造成比较大的油的恐慌
我觉得就不是现在
我觉得现在边的油价上涨
还是心理层面的部分比较多
好 所以这个我们也只能且战且走了
因为市场现在对利空是有反应的
因为前一阵子
其實像上禮拜我們一直提到一件事情
利多有點刺激不了 對不對
但利空卻很反應
這就是典型市場現在氣氛差的一個象徵所以我們要期待的是什麼我們已經不是在期待利多來救市而是利空一直測試之後不跌了我覺得至少第一件事情要做到這個
可惜現在還是在一個利空來了
但重點我還是覺得韓國人實在很猛
對 你就是真的很難想像說
8月要上路的東西突然告訴你現在馬上
但這個事情可以解決
因為他就做了嘛
他現在做了他就砍了嘛
那這個好解決
我覺得油價就要等市場氣氛的恢復
其實有個東西也可以觀察
就是美國的恐慌指數VIX指標
其實它沒有在創高喔
也代表市場對於來來回回反反覆覆的這些油價上漲或是美意之戰
它沒有覺得有更恐怖
只是就是情緒不好的一個情況
所以現在我想大家做股票會有一種脫模的感覺
它不是恐慌
它不像說最大跌點那一天或什麼
你會覺得發生什麼事
你是有點脫模
就是到底怎樣我才能恢復到我買了股票之後
只要是對著產業就能順順漲
我記得我有一次來節目
我有講說
今天發覺我們的金融哥講話了
他說我們的這個房貸打到這裡就可以了
對
對不對
我真的講說
其實市場會有可能會把資金移到房地產區
是
營建股的股票可能相對會開始變得比較好
有漲一兩天
在第三季比較不明朗的情況之下
也許它就是一個避風港
現在就有這種氛圍
就是其實資金是在避風港parking
之前比較冷的股票其實它相對不跌
反正最近起伏很大就是之前很熱的股票
很熱的族群
對 所以在這種情況下
已經很多人在裡面的戲院
你就不要再去裡面湊熱鬧了
你就先在外面等等看
或者是他之前戲院都已經沒人了
例如說CPU這種
人幾乎都跑光了
那你就可以試著進來蹲蹲看
蹲蹲看也許戲就上演了
對不對
那在這個地方你說
我剛剛講嘛
因為這個時間點大概還要拖半
2、3個禮拜
就這個盤才會開始比較穩定
那當然會有人講說
哇 2、3禮拜那是多久的時間啊
天啊 好可怕啊
對不對 所以
我們資金就可以往
相對來講位階比較低的去移
或者是我們講長線的APF其實還是好的
那它今天跌停
其實你就可以去試著
接點試試水溫
因為我剛剛講
今天APF四雄裡面
其實昨天最弱的真領
今天是沒跌停的
所以它不是基本面的問題
而是這個籌碼的部分出了問題
那我猜昨天一定也有人去追ABF
對 下來這邊我個人覺得
以ABF這四檔裡面
我認為投信對於星星跟南電一定是不離不棄
星星跟南電是不離不棄
那我們剛剛講 人家講過
星星其實是比較佔AI成分比較重的
也就是說它會是投信未來持續加碼的標的
一樣啊 其實也是
可是你看這幾天的連貌也都被殺到跌停
不過因為他前幾天抗跌
其實論仔細看
其實連貌形態是比台光跟台藥都還要強的
是比他們 明顯好
所以他有點類似補碟的概念
就是大哥沒上去
我也不能跑太遠
我就回來等待一下大哥
所以股價其實是他在告訴你說
我的位階已經很高 我需要休息
而不是說他位階很高 你要繼續追他
希望他離大哥跑更遠
這樣就有點太離譜了
有点不合
没有这个没有什么
没有道义 伦理
就是大哥还坐在那里
你跑什么
对不对
所以大哥还坐在那里
就是不能跑太远
在附近等待
所以其实是
各股还是有一些族群
脉络可循的
不完全是没有
只是我们可以看到
投信在近期的这段时间
你看他的买超前五十五大
基本上就是什么金融股
营建股
军工股
投信不太买军工股
但是投信也開始買軍工股
今天投信也開始買軍工股
就我們之前講說
軍工股可能是另外一個清流
因為他們不在AI的這個陣營裡面
而且他們從馬洗乾淨很久
對 他們從馬相對比較乾淨
所以它就是資金停車的地方
但我說它也不會停車太久
大概就是兩三週的時間
所以你要嘛就是乾脆減碼一點
也不要全部除掉
減碼一點在旁邊看
看哪些族群相對是比較穩定的
或者是你去接那個位階相對比較低的
而不是說你現在把你的資金全部壓進去
去壓未來這兩週
我覺得這樣會比較冒險
好 軍工
這個凱哥之前也有特別聊到
因為我一直很擔心軍工只有一兩日行情
而且受政策的表決影響等等
但後來凱哥就獨牌眾議說
他覺得這次真的不一樣
因為這次是朝野兩黨都有提供
像無人機方面的預算
不是正跟否
是預算到底用哪一種的版本
然後再來的話真的是變成避風港了
軍工在這段時間
大家有錢會跑去哪裡 還有素化
可是今天素化就呈現一個很奇妙的狀態
這也是我講
現在已經不是看基本面盤
它有點籌碼盤
素化不是前一陣子超級強
照理來說
今天油價上去應該更強啊
沒有 因為漲太多
漲太多錢就有一點也從素化提款了
因為他們是右上角的股票
然後像工業電腦
雖然我這段時間一直提到
他們也是屬於比較避風的
但是也要留意這個現象
今天化它還是非常強
可是會不會強一強過兩天
資金想要去找那些已經跌得比較深的就把它丟掉
這個在盤面上最近是有可能產生這樣的現象
所以都不要用
它在右上角
我現在覺得我想避風我跑去買它
好像它都不會跌
搞不好一買就跌
但反過來說有一個東西跌了
像矽晶圓
矽晶圓在環球晶傳出義大利的8吋廠
失火了
結果沒想到它會失火
全部的矽晶圓是一直跌
這個我就有點不懂
以前我們聽到這種就會想
轉單效應
因為現在產能變少了
或者是會有火險或什麼的
總之應該是往好處想
只要沒有人傷亡
這邊要講
因為我之前有遇到那種PCB版廠
後來傷亡很慘重
那個我都不敢再碰
我覺得那個真的不行
好
那為什麼這次西晶圓反而是喋喋不休
到今天還在重挫呢
我覺得其實西晶圓
你要用某個角度來看
就是說第一個是
它確實產業還在向上
對呀
它的價格也還在調漲
對
可是剛剛講的盤很弱
盤很弱的時候
大家就會把利空把它放大
其實這一波的矽晶圓最先跌的其實是合金
合金開始進入20分鐘一盤之後
它就開始拼命地
但是合金的獲利真的也比較不好
但是它基本上是領先的
那進入分盤之後它就開始往下跌
往下跌
跌一段時間
然後又遇到環球晶這事情
所以今天原本很強勢的台勝科
就連續殺下來
連續跌停
對 就變成是有點滾雪球的概念
所以解鈴還去細鈴人
就是你要看合金什麼時候可以開始
零投的
對 它就開始打底
然後開始起漲
我覺得這個族群就會開始火過來
是
否則你說它的八寸矽晶圓發生火災
其實對產業面而言
應該是會供不應求嘛
是
是正常的想法
可是你看
它的八寸矽晶圓起火燃燒
分離式元件的股票也沒有漲啊
你看什麼
副頂
什麼
分離式元件看副頂
強茂
對不對
台磐
通通都是下跌的
對
所以告訴你說
基本上現在是
不理性的
他沒有用基本面在判斷這個行情
純粹就是籌碼
對
好 公立元件的話
其實他們的營收狀況差也很大
不會必須這樣
像我們之前
我自己有在看像大中
大中是在第一季就繳出營收年增非常漂亮
可是剛剛提到不管是富頂強化台辦
都普
都是比較
不說沒成長喔
比較普
好 那當然另外一個
大家每天都會關注的就是被動元件
從暴動元件
被套元件
是
那後來更有趣的是外資報告
因為之前大摩就看到國劇1500塊以上
近期昨天有講
就突然調降了3%的目標價
3%也在出報告
然後就調降
但是花旗環球今天就講說
沒有他們覺得國劇還是1500
但這樣子到底要聽誰的
那國劇又要開法說了
我覺得這個法說就蠻值得一聽
國劇或者是其他的辯論員
例如說另外一個指標股是信倉電
被分盤交易之後超級弱
這些都可能是要等他們恢復正常
今天和聲堂還是不敵
因為和聲堂算是這一次回檔以後
法人比較青睞的
今天也是重挫
所以被動元件
主動元件
都沒有辦法恢復市場上的順行
反而跌的還是很重
我覺得被動元件
我很早就講
被動元件有兩檔股票是市場的主流
誰
就是和聲堂跟新倉店
和聲堂跟新倉店
小的是他們兩個
所以那時候
他們來講被動元件的時候
我就特別提說
基本上你要用和聲堂跟新倉店
來去判斷國具跟華星科
用他们这两党去做
其他的大型的被动引荐股对而不是用他们两家去判斷是你其實從這個型態目前來看目前和聲堂的型態還是強過果具
強過信長電
強過華興科
嗯
所以你這一波
你要等被動硬件拉起來
那你就是看和聲堂的表現
是
因為我們之前講過
他之前有個謠言
就是這個NP0要被X7R取代
有 我們聊過這件事
那我說過很多的投信
相信了這個邏輯
但我說這是不對的
嗯
因为这个X7R会造成这个电容的波动变大
在AI的伺服器里面是不容许这样的波动的
所以理论上它还是NP0的天下
但是NP0的核生糖涨太多了
可是我们最早时候涨的是200多块
涨到接近千元
我说它会重返荣耀
回完重返荣耀之后
它就下来了
所以下来了基本上它就是筹码的问题
它已经不是基本面的问题
目前这个时间点看起来
第三季的被动元件还会涨价
也还是缺
那你就说涨价缺
这不是要大买特买吗
但是筹码相对就凌乱了
是两个讲法
就是说你看投信什么时候
开始砍出国具
那就告诉你国具要落底了
那就是因为在高档的时候
其实已经有人把筹码套给投信
所以当投信丢出来之后
这个筹码就会再度回到有心人的手上
那我们就看到底是投信能够撑得住
还是有心人能够撑得住
如果投信坚持不卖
我觉得股价跌到这边
确实也应该开始要进入打底整理的阶段
投信也卖了不少
可能有留下一些
就变成在他们的
大家都在等
姚池金末
但是981A当然这段时间表现不是很好
不过昨天我也有发现也有人统计
今年以来的主动式ETF
目前981A
或者是大家喜欢991A
比较常听到这几档
甚至有一檔是横跨到美國、韓國、台灣、日本的叫做988A
它在今年這些主動式ETF的表現還是超越大盤
就等於這段時間雖然它的震盪大也扣血
可是它們卻還是能跑贏大盤
這件事情我覺得還是給予表彰啦
它們的波動本來就大
所以如果買主動式ETF的
要享受到它前面的績效
就要忍耐它現在的波動
但它們並不是一個壞掉的商品
那它們有時候可以堅持
有時候可能像以前我有跟
就前幾天我跟田友朋友講說
以前基金時代可能沒辦法這樣凹單
可能也不太可能變成隔日沖
因為有看到有的主動是今天買
明天就賣掉
對
那但是現在變成ETF好像有變得比較寬鬆
會有那種短線金儲也有
或是凹單也有
允許他們這樣做
真的喔
但是我之前講過
到第三季啊
981A就會跑得比00403來的差
我有講過
因為981A它做比較偏中小股
摄影衣服它相對來講
它是比較大型鼓的主
那這個行情基本上
目前就是屬於大型鼓相對有利
你可以看一下我們OTC的跌幅
基本上就明顯比大盤多很多
但是它也不會永遠是這樣子
就是小狗跑遠它總是會回來
但是久一久它又跑回去
所以基本上大家對於行情
基本上有個想法就是
明年的AI還是非常的好
只是這個階段
因為大家太貪心了
所以稍微在洗大家的心
磨一下大家的心
要把這個確定能夠長期投資人留下來
那如果你覺得你的買的點
可能相對不是那麼漂亮
其實你就應該在大量低就要做減碼的動作
而不是說一直要凹單
我們不是投信
投信才做白眼後的動作
我們是聰明投資人
我們是不做這件事情的
好 四零三因為他的規則
當然要跟酒吧也寫的可能稍微不一樣
不過我也必須講一件事
我覺得主動是他沒有什麼真正認真的大規格
有啦 例如說
991還是哪一家
他講的是未來50的那一家
他就有特別提到
他是從前五 150大市值
對 就會有人把這個寫進去
寫進去的話那就沒辦法
你可能就要從這150大裡面選
只是他有特別提到
他的未來50就是
那我就不是focus在現在的0050成分股
我可能是100到150
這種有機會成長到未來成為市值前50大的我優先買
像這樣的選股邏輯我覺得也不錯
其實彈性也是夠大的
因為說實話當ETF長大之後
你說他們要去買這種市值
好,不要說150,300名以後的很難了
你買不了幾張
因為你會太嚴重的影響到它的股價
所以最後981會不會變得很像0050
或者981會不會變得很像403A
會不會很貼近
這也是有可能,因為錢很多
所以我覺得那就看經理人
如何去調整他們的表現
但我覺得到目前為止
我不會覺得有什麼很失質、很糟糕
你做了很危險的事情
對,目前其實真的沒有
所以大家如果在各股產業上有信念的話
一定要記得
現在看
跟你看到明年
這是兩回事
你現在每天貼著它看
你會超級痛苦
你就會身處在洗衣機裡面
對
然後被脫水
是
可是如果你看到明年
你的心會比較定
就像剛剛凱哥講的
今天如果是全面熱門族群在跌停
你可能剪一點
全面在漲停
你千萬不要亂追
用這樣的心情去布局
或者是像造化
就有時候看不懂個股的時候
我會去剪的是ETF
用這個為主
主動是你看不懂
就剪市值嘛
再怎麼樣市值不會出亂子
甚至有人問我說
最近能不能減正二
我會說一樣的道理
你如果貼得很近去看
正二也曾經在上個禮拜的
黑色星期五跌十幾%
那你會怕
可是如果你用遠去看
市值永遠往右上
那你減一點減一點
我覺得正二也不是什麼
很邪惡的商品啦
必須這麼講喔
那不喜歡槓桿的朋友
會覺得看到韓國那樣嚇死了
當然就不用勉強自己
但是如果你要問
我個人的風險承擔度
我覺得正二也是OK的啊
對 也是OK的
所以我覺得跌到這邊
大家就是要把眼睛看遠一點
不能用近視眼了 要用遠視眼
稍微看一下
知道現狀是沒有在基本面上出現改變的
而是重麻的凌亂
剛剛講到利空測試
測試到不會跌的時候
讓我們的好日子又會重新恢復
是
好 那今天也謝謝星期五男孩
謝謝趙華
謝謝大家
有沒有什麼要特別提醒大家的風險呢
我覺得就是未來的兩週
還是一個比較整理的一個階段
所以大家不要過度的追高
那操作上基本上
我覺得我們之前還是有提到一些
相對比較安全的標的
比如說我們那時候在講說
營建股的新復發 貫德這些比較穩定
或者是產業裡面
有一些開始跨境半導體業
比如說像巧新這種
其實他們就相對比較穩定
因為他們著墨的人相對比較少
但是他們確實產業也有機會
還有就是六月營收結出來的時候我們有發現
尤其像現在關稅這件事情講出來之後
有一些所謂的價值傳產股
它還真的就是已經有繳出順行的成績單
就是他們在六月的營收有繳出接近歷史新高
或是近期新高的一個成績單的時候
你會發現這段時間他們的股價相對也是抗跌的
我覺得還有像有些軟體股也有產生這樣的一個現象
你會發現大盤在季線這邊掙扎
而他們都已經在可能時日線上、月線上
我覺得這很重要
月線保持上揚的
一直在月線上的這些股票
接觸到月線沒有再跌破的
我覺得都會是這段時間
如果你真的希望能夠好好投資的話
比較好的選擇
對 一旦破線跌下來
就像我們一直在掙扎說
我要不要抄底國具啊
我要不要抄底線舱點
No no no
不要用這樣的想法
那些只能用一點錢
一點錢去慢慢的減
可是如果你喜歡的是好股票
他們已經告訴你
他們的防禦力特別好
再搭配到六月營收
以及接下來我還是要強調
會陸陸續續第二季的季報出來
各家重要的公司都要開發說
我覺得這些要聽起來
對 聽起來你就會知道
你買的公司是好的公司
只是現在在等時機而已
是 所以這行情基本上就是
不要太心慌
基本上心頭抓好聽
這不敢想想要做紅台
就是說大盤歸大盤
你還是要你自己的一個配置的想法
那你有個忠心的主軸
你就相信AI是成長
那你就不用太害怕
不用說今天要全部砍掉不需要
但是如果你完全沒有想法
那就很危險
是
好
那今天也很謝謝我們的新喜五男孩
也希望大家在這個週末
我們就靜觀其變
真的不要太擔心
我身邊有些朋友聽起來有點焦慮
我就希望大家好好好的放鬆
享受一下這個週末
那我們今天的古惑仔就到這邊囉
大家掰掰
掰掰
拜拜
大家拜拜